cette autre édition d' espace autochtone
en direct je m'appelle anne-marie yvan
nous étions lundi à ottawa au musée de
l'histoire fait jeudi toujours à ottawa
et à chaque fois je me fais reprendre
c'est à gatineau pour le dépôt du
rapport final de l'enquêté nationale sur
les femmes et les filles autochtones
assassinées et disparues en espèces
alors y avait beaucoup de monde on a un
retour 2-0 lundi 1er juin
voilà merci c'est parti donc nous étions
là pour le rapport de l'invs fada
aujourd'hui notre émission elle est
consacrée aux réactions à ce rapport
mais surtout à la suite des choses
comment ça va se passer
alors pour en parler vivien michel la
présidente de femmes autochtones du
québec co et viviane oui viviane innu
originaire d'une belle communauté
la clippers semences malioténam à 14
kilomètres de sept ans on va savoir
d'abord avec votre voisin
steven bones pire monsieur bonne spirale
bonjour vous vous êtes un mot hague de
la communauté de cannes et s'attaquer
voilà est-ce que c'est la plus belle des
communautés je pense que on n'a pas
dormi et isabelle picard qui est wendat
originaire de la communauté de wendake
et bonjour isabelle on joue évidemment
c'est votre communauté la plus belle
gifle et on n'a pas terminé parce que
nous aurons une invitée dans quelques
instants
c'est andré vachon elle est il ou elle
aussi originaire de la communauté de
pessamit t elle va se joindre à nous au
cours des prochaines minutes
on l'attend alors ce qui est intéressant
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on parle du rapport
de cette enquête sur les femmes et les
filles autochtones est assassiné et on a
entendu très peu d'hommes et c'est pour
ça que c'est un plaisir de vous recevoir
monsieur bonne speed
merci d'avoir accepté l'invitation
donc avant toute chose on va réagir au
rapport
il est sorti on veut savoir ce que vous
en pensez viviane michel d'abord nous
informe autochtones du québec évidemment
on est très content on reconnaît le
travail vraiment important que comme si
on enquête à fait ok dans un court délai
évidemment
ça a été vraiment long comme d'autres
ont eu oui mais c'était une des
critiques que vous aviez eu tout au long
du rapport aussi à le fait qu'il ya des
délais très courts mais des gens qu'un
la commission avait amorcé son travail
en janvier puis la rencontre des
organisations autochtones et on avait
soumis à la table des jo de demander un
délai parce qu'on savait que les délais
des très courts et que femme autochtone
était prêt à supporter justement la
demande de délai sauf que le délai d
venu un peu plus tard oui donc ça
raccourci vraiment les travaux de la
commission
oui deux cent trente et une
recommandation bon je sais pas si vous
avez eu le temps de passer à travers
toutes plus des recommandations
spécifiques pour le québec
vous êtes satisfaite de ces
recommandations principalement ceux
concernant le québec
évidemment nous on a fait l'exercice de
framatome du québec de lire le rapport
est de faire les comparaisons parce que
femmes autochtones du québec a déposé un
mémoire avec 80 une recommandation ou
est-ce qu'on a consulté des intervenants
qui travaillent directement avec des
victimes le réseau des maisons
d'hébergement et les familles aussi
évidemment
donc on a fait des comparaisons et on
est très satisfaits dans le sens que nos
recommandations apparaissent beaucoup
dans le rapport national donc pas les 80
une dans le dans les rapports oui oui
qu'on a vraiment tenu compte de ce que
vous aurez marre vraiment parce que ça a
été vraiment des bonnes recommandations
pour les familles évidemment les
monnaies vent jeu de formes au doctorat
on va pouvoir en parler si von bonn
spears votre réaction au rapport de
l'enesad ah ben je suis satisfait de
leur répondre
j'essaie ya beaucoup de délai mais si ça
prend 3 1 4 1 pour perso il faut faire
prendre le temps pour faire un bonne
réponse et je pense que toutes les
organisations autochtones partout au
canada est ce qu'avec et interviews
jusqu'à colons britanniques
tout le monde fait le pas même les
familles les femmes des jeunes filles
même les ans il fait le travail ensemble
pour avoir un bon rapport sur cet essai
de sa femme sait c'est la première étape
il ya dose de tapie poursuit vaisseau
mais comme ici à québec on a des
recommandations pour jusqu'ici pour la
province québec pour les relations entre
les autochtones et les sociétés blais
toutes les organisations comme les
polices romandes québec les
municipalités tout ça il faut travailler
sur soi
isabelle c'est un rapport qui m'apparaît
ma foi très complet un rapport j'ai
senti une grande écoute de la part des
commissaires qui vient le disais les
familles ont témoigné aussi j'avais j'ai
eu la chance lundi d'être assise parmi
les familles lors de la cérémonie et les
échos que j'ai entendu c'est bien ce
qu'on a dit ça s'y retrouve et ça je
pense que c'était le plus important
le rapport ma part est complet d'autres
diront qu'ils vont dans toutes les
directions mais ça m'apparaît c'est
nécessaire dans une situation comme
celle là puisque le mandat de l'aisne
fadasse était de trouver les causes et
il y en a pas seulement une caserne
plusieurs exactement alors maintenant le
rapport est déposé
tout le monde a tourné autour du terme
génocide on ya passé énormément de temps
ne le fera pas aujourd'hui je pense
qu'on en a assez parlé maintenant c'est
le temps d'agir
comment est-ce qu'on peut commencer avec
un rapport aussi volumineux là je n'ai
pas à porter mais c'est 1200 pages c'est
épais comme ça il ya tellement de
travail
par quoi on commence moi je pense que
non une responsabilité justement de lire
le rapport d'analysé le rapport et comme
nous on a fourni les comparaisons avec
les 80 une recommandation oui et sap
ainsi un sens de vouloir changer les
choses ok pour rien qu aux organisations
autochtones dont ont beau faire plus tôt
un appel à la collaboration qui veut
changer les choses qui veut améliorer
pour ferme autochtones du québec ça a
été vraiment améliorer les
la sécurité publique et la justice parce
qu'on sait que s'il ya eu des
manquements par rapport à des femmes des
corps de femmes autochtones disparues
assassinées c'est que la sécurité
publique ne s'applique pas pour les
femmes autochtones
donc est-ce qu'on peut changer les
choses je crois que oui
le dépôt du rapport tombe vraiment dans
un bon timing
ce qui veut dire on est en période
d'élections maintenant ou dans les
recommandations qui sont sur la table et
c'est sûr que nous en tant
qu'organisation on ne vaut pas les
tables étaient si ces recommandations là
on va faire des approches avec des
gouvernements avec des civils avec des
organisations qui veulent apporter un
changement à au point de vue de ses
vengeurs vraiment majeur avez vous
l'impression que la la société
canadienne et la société québécoise est
derrière les femmes autochtones et
derrière justement ce besoin de
réparation et de changer les choses là
d'agir concrètement
isabelle j'ai senti une réponse
différente de la part des hommes
canadiens et des femmes canadiennes et
sa gelée senti très clairement au niveau
des chroniqueurs qui se sont exprimés
comme le soin par les médias écrits ou à
la télévision
j'ai senti plus d'empathie de la part
des femmes et le gpo fed et tout
sociologique mais c'est un courant puis
viviane je pense que tu peux tu peux
voir la même chose
c'est un courant que j'ai ressenti que
j'ai vu que j'ai entendu je pense que
les femmes ça vient chercher les femmes
canadiennes évidemment ça vient chercher
quelque chose à l'intérieur d'elle que
les hommes peut-être n'ont pas la même
sensibilité quoique sais pas
je vais pas faire de généralités ici
bien sûr mais j'ai senti une grande
empathie de l'apport défendre des femmes
canadiennes donc ça ça m'apparaît
extrêmement important et vraiment
intéressant
maintenant c'est sûr que le mot génocide
a fait en sorte que certains ont remué
les maintenant dans la semaine que passé
il ya une belle évolution lundi c'était
génocide génocide n'y a pas eu de
génocide et tranquillement les gens ont
lu le rapport complémentaire justement
sur la notion de génocide qui a été fait
aussi par l'amf ada et ils ont compris
que bon génocide ça pouvait être autre
chose que dans l'immédiat que que la
chaux ya que le rwanda est donc une
évolution j'aiderai dans dans les
mentalités je pense et je pense que ça
va continuer ça m'apparaît quand même
somme toute positif j'espère que ça va
continuer dans ce sens et dans les
communautés
est ce que tout le monde est prêt à agir
stevens pire vous êtes un ancien grand
chef si un grand chef de kanesatake et
est ce que dans les communautés les
conseils de bande sont prêts à se mettre
au travail
je pense qu'il est toujours prêt pour
défendre nos intérêts pour défendre
notre société et nos femmes nos enfants
il est toujours prêt pour travail est
souvent nos applications nos mots
tombent sol et les oreilles des
documents mais ils soudent il n'écoute
pas ses prix en faut dire la même chose
sans fois juste pour le goût mandat
d'écouté d'écouté qu'est ce qui se passe
dans nos communautés
mais j'ai beaucoup confiance dans nos
conseils demande et plus j'ai plus de
confiance dans les organisations
autochtones comme l'affirma totale du
québec qui bouge qui fait d'elle tout le
travail
ah c'est ça ou en faut mettre nos
efforts on met notre soutien quand il ya
de nos femmes pour faire le travail
c'est un rapport national c'est le
gouvernement fédéral qui le chapeaute
maintenant il ya des gouvernements
provinciaux ça va être à eux de
l'appliquer en fait un dans chaque
province chacun va
un travail à faire est ce que les
gouvernements provinciaux s qu'ici au
québec
le gouvernement est prêt à appuyer ce
travail là je pense que les travaux de
la commission a quand même apporté
beaucoup dans le sens d'une grande
éducation populaire comme on pourrait
dire mais aussi une grande
sensibilisation auprès du public
il ya une responsabilité du citoyen
aussi parce que même dans le rapport il
ya le point 15 ou est ce que henry que
le citoyen les gens demandent toujours
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour la cause
des femmes autochtones
allez voir dans le rapport oui le point
elles ont une responsabilité
d'interpeller leurs seins et leurs élus
ce qui veut dire leurs députés et c est
de bien choisir moi mais ça c'est
vraiment un gros défi de bien choisir un
gouvernement qui est capable d'apporter
des changements c'est tout un travail
collectif qui doit se faire pour rien
qu'elle femmes autochtones du québec
mais à l'ample je pense du québec
on va parler québec parce qu'il ya un
rapport du québec aussi sa réplique le
citoyen ça implique autant les
autochtones s'en est pris comme temps
les organisations autochtones
ça implique les chefs évidemment on peut
pas passer à côté et ça implique la
tante de responsabilité de la sécurité
publique et de la justice et du
gouvernement
oui qu'on sait que s'il ya des codes de
femmes autochtones disparues assassinées
c'est qui encore l'impunité qui est
encore qui est encore existants donc on
nous ce qu'on veut on veut éliminer et
on veut donner de l'importance à des cas
de disparitions et d'assassinats
donc il ya un souci de travail qui doit
se faire
on parle du changement le changement
c'est ça a été de 3 on commence c'est
pas aucun qu'il faut avoir une élection
suspense est ici et maintenant qu'on
doit être un mobilisation qu'on doit
aider jean 1 action pour apporter ce
changement alors vous mettez beaucoup
l'emphase sur la sécurité publique et la
justice
est ce que ce sont justement ces deux
aspects là qui sont les plus importants
à travers à travers toutes les
discussions à travers les
recommandations qui sont mises en place
mais en quoi ils sont pour ma part
tellement ceux qui sont les il ya
urgence d'agir au niveau là on est plus
laisser des femmes qu'elles soient
autochtones ou à l'automne disparaître
victime de violence d'assassinât et donc
pour moi urgence d'agir au niveau des
relations avec les services policiers au
niveau du système de justice est là on
doit commencer d'après moi par ça outre
évidemment un plan d'action qui doit
être réalisée également pour l'ensemble
des 231 de recommandations mais
maintenant plusieurs familles se sont
plaints à travers le processus qu'elle
n'avait pas des coudes quand elle est
allée voir la police kong à l'apport
dire ma soeur ma cousine et disparus on
sait pas ce que c'est pas assez
et souvent ce qu'on entendait cbc une
fugue ou bon elle consommait alors oui
et ça ces préjugés le douaisis
stéréotypes là il faut enlever ça et
c'est majeur déjà ses relations l'eau
doivent être grandement améliorée oui
alors quand on parle des policiers on
parle autant des policiers non
autochtone kotok tonnes qui agissent
dans les communautés oui aussi bien sûr
au niveau des policiers autochtones ce
qu'on ne lui dans le rapport c'est qu'il
ya un sous financement au niveau des
services policiers dans les communautés
ce qui va faire en sorte que les
enquêtes des fois vont devoir être beau
bâclé mais réglée de manière dont
succincte et donc ce sous-financement
lavaud joué un rôle important dans les
réalités des femmes autochtones au
canada
oui monsieur bones pire sous financement
de la des corps policiers vous êtes
d'accord avec ça vous le voyez
évidemment vous n'êtes plus grands chefs
alors mais vous allez parler en votre
nom parce que vous l'avez été vous avez
travaillé dans une communauté en tant
que chef et en tant que grand chef est
ce que c'est une réalité récurrentes
ce jour là oui mais ça existe depuis que
gérer ni il y en à nos propres services
de police dans nos communautés et papa
chaque unité mais en a
quand police autochtone qui existe en
plusieurs communautés
mais c'est toujours la question des
fonds sous financement des jeunes
accordent police même ça c'est pas la
seul secteur qui est sous financement on
a d'autres qui peut aider à nos enfants
nos jeunes philosophes m pour avoir un
meilleur avenir c'est pas juste la
police qui va régler tout le sait la
société en tout
oui oui comme l'éducation santé on a
besoin plus pour nos peuples pour avoir
mes meilleurs à venir mais surtout ma
dans le bonheur pour cette problématique
qui existe depuis 200 300 année là avec
la chronique aux hommes en anglais mais
avec ça il ya beaucoup d'éléments qui
bouge a le même temps c'est pas juste
une deux pour régler le problème en
infos adressé à deux autres éléments qui
bougent à l'émeute
c'est important pour nous autres alors
donc parmi ses autres films à quoi vous
pensez des autres éléments à pour moi
c'est toujours une question de société
dans nos communautés pour plus de
soutien pour notre système d'éducation
de systèmes de santé pour nono nos aînés
nos jeunes eux mêmes pauvres dans la
halle secteur des sports le secteur de
l'éducation le secteur de la santé
sociaux tout ça qui est la chose qui est
très important pour moi mais pour c'est
là notre culture et élan ça c'est la
baojun anacarde ce qu on appelle ça
empire tout et ça c'est notre el himma
que la citerne
c'est à cause des chroniques des
obsessions vous avez de la culture et la
langue en ville est longue
d'ailleurs les langues font partie des
recommandations les sports on veut que
les langues toutes les langues
autochtones redeviennent des langues
officielles au même titre que le
français et l'anglais
la culture aussi
et ça se comprend très bien parce que à
partir du moment où une personne
autochtone un homme ou une femme connaît
sa culture connaissent sa langue sa
spiritualité aussi nécessairement
d'après moi en quoi ils vont être plus
fort une meilleure estime d'elle même et
donc va être peut-être moins portés à
consommer vont être moins portés aussi
avoir des relations avec des personnes
qui sont nocifs pour pour l ouïe donc ça
fait partie de tous qu'on voit pas des
fois on dit bien certains les loin il
lui parle de culture et de langue mais
ça fait partie de tout ça c'était sim de
soi que la femme autochtone perdu à
travers les années à cause du
colonialisme notamment et de tout ce que
ce qui le composent et la culture et la
langue c'est un élément de fierté quand
possède sort on est fiers on est plus
forts on est plus affirmée ça m'apparaît
essentiel qu'est ce qu'on peut déjà
appliquées qu est-ce qu on peut déjà
mettre en place vous l'avez dit bon le d
le rapport a été déposé le diront dès
vendredi des gens devraient commencer à
agir par quoi on devrait agir
immédiatement la caisse qui est possible
de mettre en place maintenant vivia pour
femmes autochtones du québec évidemment
améliorer le la sécurité publique et
mais ça c'est comment savait comment je
pense que les les gens ont reçu ou le
reçoit maintenant leur apprends je pense
qu'ils ont a énuméré aussi leur pente
responsabilité et par la suite bon
est-ce qu'on peut établir justement une
bande de collaboration femmes
autochtones du québec est prêt à
travailler avec justement ces gens qui
veulent la porter le sens pas on est
prêts à apporter notre expertise on est
prêt à porter ce qu'on a déposé comme
recommandation il faut bouger je pense
qu'on ne peut pas juste faire une
commission une grande commission
nationale et 10 rebonds mais c'est fait
on pour sa autre chose non pour faire
autre chose c'est d ici maintenant et
vous changez comment on va travailler
ensemble et c'est là je pense le défi
qu'ont à faire le travailler ensemble
s'est pas décidé pour nous arrêtons
d'exercer ses formes coloniale on parle
de colonialisme évidemment as
lyon nous oui bon osons bâtir enfants
donc à essayer de voir comment nous on
perçoit les meilleures solutions et
aidez-nous justement à changer vos
pratiques améliorées les plus pratiques
qui ne se fait pas la réflexion doit se
faire donc différent mais voilà à quoi
on change les rôles de place la voilà
est important pour nous l'inclusion et
nous inclure dans ce processus là nous
consulter nous concerter moares que le
produit qu'on a enfin dans le plan si on
fait un plan de match son ensemble se
voir qu'est ce qui est écrit ce que
c'est vraiment dans ce conte qu'on
s'attend à travailler ça vaut vraiment
loin puis tout à l'heure on parlait de
colonne coloniale dé c'est l'héritage
colonial encore qui est exercée on est
en 2010 n'a fait les gens décident
encore pour nous on a des belles valant
on a des belles visions est ce qu'on
peut nous rendre cette autonomie je
pense que oui on connaît les des besoins
de nos gens on connaît nos solutions il
faut reconnaître aussi une solution à
quelques bons mais comment ça va se
passer alors est-ce qu'on va vous dire
justement vous prenez le dossier en main
vous le gérer et vous vous vous
impliquez oui les non autochtones mais à
la base c'est vous qui partez avec le
les changements et sait plus comment ça
va me demander à prendre toutes les
recommandations c'est quand même un
possible quand comprendre de
collaboration c'est comment on voit
s'asseoir piquer des allers retours
d'information qu'est ce qui a été fait
car qu'on a déposé une autre mémoire et
on a demandé dans notre mémoire d'avoir
un comité de suivi
suite aux recommandations du rapport qui
va être déposée lorsque si on se réfère
à la cvr la sévère données 94
recommandations via sion will saison oui
qui qui ont réalisé les recommandations
qui sont là et maintenant est-ce qu'on
peut changer la façon de voir les choses
est ce qu'on peut savoir que telle
organisation ou mettant la sécurité
publique on travaille aussi avec
d'autres au togo ne supporte que en iran
dessus l'aude la transparence on parle
de transparence bons ballons bearer
verset 2 mois oui alors revenons
justement la commission vérité
réconciliation
sur les 94 recommandations quelques unes
ont été appliquées comment est ce qu'on
peut penser que ça va se passer mieux
cette fois ci avec le rapport de l'ong
fada et qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour
que justement ça se passe là pied au cul
rond soit pas encore en attente que ça
se réalise
isabelle en fait je pense que
le plan d'actions l'établissement d'un
plan d'action va être vraiment important
puisque c'est uniquement de cette façon
là qu'on va savoir vraiment où 120
plants d'exemple quinquennal on verra
comme viviane le disais il va falloir
vraiment changé la manière de faire les
choses
donc ça ne sort plus du gouvernement
fédéral envers les organisations
autochtones
ce doit être ça doit être un niveau au
moins au minimum égal
oui donc vraiment s'entendre sur une
démarche une manière de faire les choses
par des valeurs de réciprocité de
transparence c'est essentiel mais le
plan d'action c'est ce qu'il faut faire
en sorte qu'on va être capable de
mesurer aussi les progrès à chaque année
c'est ce qu'il n'y a pas eu dans les
autres commissions qu'on a vu les autres
enquêtes
donc ça c'est c'est absolument important
de le faire rapidement parce que si on
attend encore minces et combien d'autres
femmes autochtones qui vont être décédés
ou qui vont être disparu il ya urgence
d'agir et le ccc un appel important que
j'aurais d'ailleurs depuis que le cep
tant qu'aide elle a été mise en place
les disparitions n'ont pas cessé les
meurtres n'ont pas cessé les choses
n'ont pas changé du tout en fait non non
il ya 130 homicide si je me souviens
bien depuis le début des travaux de la
commission encore en fin de semaine il y
avait sur mon fil d'actualité facebook
de femmes autochtones disparues
will dans kick qu'on cherchait un peu
partout et sont notre dans nos réseaux
et la réalité elle est encore tout à
fait existant aujourd'hui le cpo quelque
chose qui s'est passé dans les années 80
et qui est ce là et c'est ou non
absolument pas alors nous allons
accueillir notre autre invitée elle est
en studio à québec elle s'appelle andré
vachon andré bonjour vous nous entendez
andré non elle nous entend pas encore
donc on va donner le temps à tous nos
techniciens de régler le son et on
devrait la retrouver dans quelques
instants
alors stephen bones pire vous ce que
vous avez eu le temps de lire le rapport
de passer à travers deux dents et skate
des recommandations qui pour vous sont
cruciales plus importante que d'eau
autre point chaud je suis pas le temps
pour lire toute la france parce que vous
avez vous avez un autre emploi je vais
dire votre poste directeur des
opérations au centre de ressources sur
la gestion des terres des premières
nations
mais j'écoute l'été les gens j'écoute
oui parce que pour vous qu'est-ce qui
serait primordiale c'est l'action c'est
toujours le même les autres enquêtes qui
parce que c'est comme en cent
quatre-vingts size le cap et les
théories toutes les recommandations plus
que 400 recommandations de tous les 400
peut-être il ya ces pétitions royale sur
les peuples autochtones
c'est la plus ancienne celle de 1976
tout ça peut être oui ou d autres que
vous m'en provincial
mais ce camp se lavent orienté est-ce
que les gourmands ils capables de deux
ils capables de pas toujours mais par
caméra de fait l'action concrets de
travail avec nos jours pour moi ça c'est
de la clé c'est toujours ça est-ce que
les gourmands est prête pour faire
quelque chose
pas juste pour jaser actuellement on va
faire un plein d'action tout ça a baissé
mais non donnez-moi le une action
concrète que tu peux faire avec
avec nous ont pas pour nous emmener avec
nous mais là est ce que le gouvernement
les gouvernements sont prêts avez vous
l'impression c'est facile à dire pour
justin trudeau il
on va en élection dans les dans les
prochaines semaines dans les prochains
mois on ne connaît pas son avenir
politique alors lui peut dire oui je
reconnais si je reconnais ça mais quand
ce sera le temps d'appliquer les choses
s'il n'est plus au pouvoir
est-ce qu'on peut autant espéré avec un
autre gouvernement
mais ça revient justement on travaille
qu'on aura faire un point qu'aux
organisations autochtones ou en tant que
première nation de pousser des choses et
de faire un
elle le gouvernement a mis sur pied une
commission d' enquête et que c'est
possible vers une commission denquête
mais si on veut apporter du changement
il faut que l'action vont avec la
commission avec le rapport qui a été
déposé dans ça c'est dur labeur qu'on a
à faire mais l'organisation l'otan
allait renoncer aller cogner aux portes
à les y regardent et testent ya pas de
sentiment
je pensais c'est vraiment un travail
collectif qui doit se faire au juste
les organisations autochtones au temps
des communautés ou temps là nos leaders
politiques oui on s'est responsabilité
de faire cette pression et la population
en général la population en général à
des recommandations là on leur dit parce
que quand on parle de la problématique
des femmes autochtones disparues
assassinées on sait que ça fait 30 ans
que quand on conduit ou et franck à
cette problématique là que l'impunité
elle est encore présent c'est bien grâce
à la population québécoise
oui parce qu'elle s'est jointe à nous
dans la mobilisation que eu dans les
vigies qu'on a eu les marchés eu
beaucoup d'éducation populaire légal
citoyens québécois canadien lutte avec
les peuples autochtones
salah plus d'impact pas représentés ou
le mode gouvernement fait un peu plus
attention parce que le rire ses citoyens
qui créent ou écran où étaient des
autochtones
oui alors on va l'accueillir tout de
suite notre invité à québec elle est là
andré vachon bonjour bonjour voilà alors
rendrez vous êtes la soeur d'adèle
patricia vachon bellefleur surnommé
aussi à des lui ce n'est ce pas dans la
communauté
adele qui est décédé en 2011 dans la
communauté de pessamit tu andré comment
vous recevez ce rapport de l'onu fada
les recommandations qui est apportée à
ce que ça met un baume sur votre coeur
oh oui c'est ça met un baume sur le cas
mais j'ai la justice n'a jamais été à
droite je crois sincère
sincèrement encore le site war l'homme
est très mais très faible parce que les
laits pourquoi à tous les jours je me
demande c'est quoi ces quoique s'est
passé est ce que dans les
recommandations on demande de rouvrir
certaines enquêtes est ce que c'est
quelque chose qui peut être possible
est ce que dans votre cas andré dans le
cas de votre famille est ce qu'on vous a
n'ont pas promis mais b dit que
peut-être oui ce serait éventuellement
possible de de rouvrir le dossier de
rouvrir l'enquêté de comprendre ce qui
est arrivé à votre jeune soeur elle
avait 17 ans à l'époque n'ont pas je
peux discuter à parler parce que j'ai
des bois c'est encore mais c'est normal
c'est normal
non y'a papa personnes qui nous
rapproche nous a rapprochés pour rouvrir
l'entente puis j'aimerais qu'un jour que
l'anc est ce ce serait au pouvoir sera
ouverte de nouveau oui ça c'est votre
espoir finalement un oui pour comment le
questionnement qui puisse avoir de
réponse oui oui absolument
votre votre famille est toujours
installé et sami de comment ça se passe
pour la famille qui est restée sur place
vous vous vivez maintenant plus à québec
n'est ce pas oui moi je le mets en plus
acculé jeunes savent qu'il demeure à 7
sous ma lieutenant oui je mets deux
frères qui demeure à personne
après l'événement ce qui se passe moi
j'ai
j'ai 100 auprès d'un coup canal comme
j'ai fui je voulais fuir le des puits
encore aujourd'hui je peux je n'arrive
pas à réaliser
réalisée il n'est plus ici
oui est-ce que vous avez du support l
enquête nationale est venu vous
rencontrez en fait lorsque l'enquêté
passé à maliotenam c'était en novembre
2010 est vous les avez rencontrées vous
avez témoignée est-ce que depuis ce
temps là il y a un support est ce qu'on
vous aide à passer à travers cette
épreuve mais j'étais chercher de l'aide
moi même puis 15 j'appelais la boll pour
demander pour avoir quelqu'un dans le
bureau ce qu'est la femme la fin oui il
y avait juste c'était beaucoup de plus
des anglophones qui me répondait avec
n'avait pas personne qui parlait
vraiment français donc on n'a pas pu
vous aider alors aujourd'hui est ce que
vous vous attendez à ce qu on vous
apporte de l'aide
je pourrais dire oui mais c'est vous qui
allez la chercher c'était de la
principalement c'est vous qui vous vous
dites moi qu'est pour vous en sortir
c'est moi qui a été chercher de leur jeu
fait mais des mouvements 9 est ce que
dans la communauté de pessamit des
histoires comme la vôtre est ce qu'il y
en a beaucoup vous êtes originaire de
pessamit donc on va parler de cette
communauté en particulier
des histoires comme ça non j'en ai pas
vraiment attendu alors qu'est ce qu'est
ce qu'on pourrait en fait heureusement
qui en a pas beaucoup d'ailleurs
heureusement mais qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire dans votre communauté quand vous
regardez comment ça déroule dans votre
communauté qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
pour aider les femmes de la commune
tu es et des communautés en général bon
parce que souvent les histoires se
ressemblent
je crois qu'il faudrait faire beaucoup
de sensibilisation la prévention auprès
des jeunes dans les écoles aussi pic
inquiets qui auraient des intervenants
ce n'est pas moins affable récent le
pressent de la paye que tu pourrais
appeler quelqu'un tu es perdu en
détresse opérées jeudi de parler à
quelqu'un
oui avoir de lait coûte en fait d'eux
les contenus oui absolument
est ce que dans les recommandations
viviano michel est ce que s'en fait
partie salle écoute l'a amené justement
des ressources pour aider les femmes les
jeunes filles les enfants aussi on va
revenir avec ce que steven apporter tout
à l'heure l'accès à la santé que ce
terreau on sait que toutes les
communautés autochtones sont en mode
survivance économique dont l'accès au
service est très limité qu'on n'en
recommande évidemment pour des familles
qui vivent des traumatismes de ce genre
qui est un accès aux services
supplémentaires
quand il ya eu le corps en 2015 est 25
ans subi les brutalités policières et la
fameuse enjeux des femmes autochtones
disparues assassinées
les gens sont laissés à eux mêmes avec
leur traumatisme
donc nous ce qu'on a recommandé dans
leurs recommandations
c'est d'avoir une clinique de trop m'en
fous travail et d'être humains parce que
les gens restent avec leur traumatisme
avec deux autres main sans avoir de
service lit et on va pas demander dans
la communauté à un travailleur social d
aider ces femmes il faut que ce soit un
service supplémentaire spécifique pour
parce qu'ils les travers sociaux sont
déjà débordés en europe on n'en tenez
encore une tâche de plus donc ça c'est
des besoins réels qui devrait exister à
l'intérieur des communautés comme à
l'extérieur des communes au bruit oui
andré l'aide que vous êtes allé chercher
vous êtes allé la chercher dans votre
communauté ou à l'extérieur de la
communauté
à l'extérieur la commune la communauté
et en ce qui concerne votre soeur et
votre mère aussi votre mère je pense vit
toujours à pessamit
est ce que est ce que toutes les deux
ont eu du support de l'intérieur de la
communauté
non ma et certains corps des personnes
souffrent bien souffre encore oui et ça
fait déjà huit ans 1
oui et ça fait déjà huit ans oui ouais
ce qui n'est pas évident du tout et
c'est pour ça qu'en fait que les choses
doivent changer extrêmement rapidement
oui c'est pas normal d'entendre ça
encore aujourd'hui que pourvu de deux
supports qu'un homme a plus que ça dans
les communautés je pense que la
recommandation de ferme autochtone pour
une clinique de trauma par élément
essentiel oui si on veut guérir ses
blessures lors qu'on veut pas qu'on se
passe d'une génération à l'autre
oui quand on le veuille ou non c'est
comme ça que ça se passe il faut que ça
s'arrête maintenant on parlait de la
création d'un poste de protecteur du
citoyen qui ressemblerait un peu à ce
modèle au modèle québécois
mais évidemment qu'il deviendrait un
expert là des enjeux des affaires
autochtones
est ce que à partir de là ça pourrait
débloquer sur sur plein d'autres
dossiers que ce soit la sécurité
publique la police la santé l'éducation
mais je pense quand carlos ça va
dépendre de son mandat et de ses
pouvoirs
est ce qu'un homme goodman est ce que
il heureux de réels pouvoirs il ya
quelque chose de politique aussi là
dedans donc il faut définir davantage
mais on doit donner si on veut que ça
donne quelque chose oui parce que s'il
fait juste recevoir les plaintes
puis on sait pas trop où ça s'en va ça
fonctionne repas il faut que ça soit
bien structurée tout ce bien établie et
il faut que ça soit fait en
collaboration encore une fois avec les
peuples autochtones pour que justement
on plus que sept
les fonctions de cette personne ne
puisse répondre aux besoins des
organisations des femmes des forums des
autochtones en général oui il ya un
autre rapport qui va bientôt sortir ce
celui de la commission vient donc la
commission vient commission d' enquête
sur les relations entre les autochtones
et des services certes en fait oui
certains services publics c'est de
certains qui est important aussi
l'attend est-ce que éventuellement on va
pouvoir ramasser les deux rapports pour
ce qui concerne le québec les mettre
ensemble et travailler conjointement
avec les deux commissions pour que ça
s'applique est ce que c'est quelque
chose de possible ou au contraire parce
que d'abord les enjeux avec la police
vont ressortir un espace la sécurité
publique aussi la justice va ressortir
dans les deux cas il y aura sûrement des
recommandations qui seront similaires
également
est ce que l'on doit attendre que ce
rapport la sorte ou agir tout de suite
mais éventuellement en tenir compte
mais là si on revient à la case de
départ ouais y'a un rapport qui est se
re qui a été mis sur matin louis partant
de ce rapport pourrait déjà un action un
certain monopole deuxième rapport de la
commission vient qui vont toucher
beaucoup oui les les endroits publics
les services publics la protection de la
jeunesse mais aussi encore une fois
parce que l'on non intervenue deux fois
la sécurité publique est important pour
nous mais l'amélioration la sécurité
publique et la justice
ok primordial est primordial c'est
vraiment un pour nous c'est vraiment
notre langage non vraiment à vouloir si
on veut vraiment travailler la
problématique des femmes autochtones
disparues assassinées
si on veut travailler la problématique
n'a brutalité policière on se cassera
pas parce qu'on est revenu deux fois
faire un rappel n'oublions pas que les
commissions étaient me pousser
c'est 2 ces deux sujets le départ bien
aux dépens ou et voilà donc faut se
centrer pour un changement un changement
au niveau de la sécurité
oui nous famous auront besoin de
sécurité
pourquoi est-ce qu'on peut pas avoir
cette sécurité l'eau comme tout être
humain
peu importe les choix des gens dans
lequel le travail on parlait tout à
l'heure j'ai écouté isabelle
d'étiquettage on étiquette on met une
étiquette à oahu une femme parce qu'elle
a décidé de faire la prostitution et le
besoin de sécurité et leur besoin d'être
protégés cas quelle qu'elles appellent à
l'aide
où saddam sécurité publique donc on se
doit
moi je pense qu'on est rendu dans un
temps où on doit mettre de l'importance
aussi quand c'est des codes de femmes
autochtones
qu'on arrête justement de nos
discriminer qu'on arrête aussi de nous
faire sentir qu'on est des moins que
rien
oui parce qu'on est des cibles
aujourd'hui on est les meilleurs cible
parce que l'impunité les cinq ans
exerçait louis steven et quel rôle
doivent jouer les hommes autochtone on
va parler des hommes en général les des
hommes autochtones dont vous êtes
autochtone et je pense que vous vous
êtes le mieux placé pour nous en parler
aujourd'hui
ben c'est important pour pour les hommes
de la même chose écoutez qu'est ce qui
se passe parce que ça c'est que tu n'as
sa norma dvno nièce qui est un trouble
qui passe par les chemins vraiment
difficiles
on est là pour dan au soutien mais aussi
pour ouvrir des portes pour travailler
sans perçu suivi le même chemin que nos
femmes parce que dans notre société mais
non ça a été mon box et les femmes qui
est des leaders oui toujours comme ça et
dans ce cas était en général pour les
autres actes ans et les femmes qui
jouait le héros très important c'est le
temps pour les hommes de protège pour
travailler ensemble avec nos femmes pour
être juste pour respecter leur décision
met au travail
mais je savais que les faits mais pour
ouvrir des propres nouvelles pour régler
le problème
adresser les problèmes qui existent dans
nos communautés et ailleurs parce que
c'est pas juste dans les petit comité ou
ce existe des problèmes car nos fermes
par pour un ville où comme il parle en
val d'aran rwanda ou à cette aile ça
c'est le problème suivent et c'est
quelque chose qu'on doit adresser tout
de suite pour protéger nos vins où ils
travaillent et travaillent ou et promène
en faux problème d'insécurité sacem nous
sommes la première pub de sept terrains
là mais dans toutes les îles de kata de
vie en calda nous sommes en dernière
place
ce panneau masse on a peu parlé de la
loi sur les indiens mais j'ai
l'impression qu'elle est crucial dans
ces enjeux là parce que tant qu'on
n'aura pas modifié la loi sur les
indiens temps qu'on leur a pas
transformer le rôle de la femme va
toujours être moindres est selon la la
loi sur les indiens le rôle de la femme
il est complètement effacé la journée où
on va faire ces modifications est ce que
ça va aider à transformer la société et
la place des femmes autochtones
isabelle je pense que oui mais encore là
ça n'est pas comment c'est fait tout est
dans le coma je pense
oui c'est de ça dont on parle depuis
tout arrêter là nous on a fait comme
femme autochtone comme comme un
autochtone on a fait notre bout de
chemin avec ce rapport là qui malgré ma
foi comme je disais très complet très
fort très transparent il faut voir la
réception aussi à un autre niveau des
autres gouvernements
maintenant qu'on parle de la loi sur les
indiens c'est sûr que les femmes ont été
discriminées doublement de par la race
puis de par le jean donc c'est évident
que ça les a touchés ça les a affectés
énormément et avec tout ce qu'elle
comptait la loi sur les indiens ont fait
en sorte que ce qu'on vit aujourd'hui
baisse c'est un peu la source de tout ça
donc on doit repenser effectivement la
loi sont les indiens de manière assez
rapide je pense que ça peut aider les
choses mais on sait peu ya quand même un
point d'interrogation
oui mais en même temps la loi sur les
indiens étaient un bon mécanisme
justement quand qu'on pende merci bien
sûr le servait vraiment un but précis
c'est vraiment l'extinction de ton
existence
c'est vraiment un but précis et en même
temps oui elle discrimine les femmes
vraiment c'est les vins qui sont touchés
père dans l'océan indien
tant qu'à moi c'est vraiment le rêve
idéal d'abolir d'amorcer justement un
travail pour abolir la loi sur les
indiens comme on l'avait sorti
dernièrement qu on a fait comme une
cuvée presse là dessus et lorsqu'on
travaille on lutte contre la loi sur les
indiens
alors on parlait des femmes et je vais
le mentionner aussi les femmes les
filles des personnes by spirit ul
lesbienne gay bisexuelle transgenre
couru en questionnement intersexuels et
asexuels d'automne je pense que toutes
ces personnes là se retrouvent un dans
cette situation difficile
avant de nous quitter parce que le temps
presse andré quel est votre espoir
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous avez de
l'espoir et qu'elle est il cet espoir
est vrai un peu d'espoir que l' enquête
soirée où va
voilà j'espère que votre message sera
entendu merci andré
merci beaucoup isabelle quel est votre
espoir isabelle en terminant il ne faut
pas que ce rapport leur de 1 soit
tabletté il faut travailler ensemble en
tant que non seulement au niveau des
gouvernements et des organisations des
premières nations mais aussi travailler
avec les citoyens canadiens
c'est absolument essentiel voilà steven
mais pour moi c'est pour avancer la
cause de l' enquête d'action concret
mais il faut un travail avec le remords
que les gars de conduire une bonne du
bon ben c'est ce qu'on appel à
l'assistance de la force strictes pour
avancer avec ça voilà il y vient on
parle de changement évidemment je pense
que le changement on est prêt à faire le
changement
on est prêt à collaborer on est dans un
bon temps justement pour ramener un
changement ensemble collectivement et
moi je vais interpeller les citoyens à
aller voir les 1200 pages informez vous
vous allez voir qui a ta place pour tout
le monde pour ramener un changement le
mode d'action est vraiment important
faut être en action le but de femmes
autochtones du québec s'est pas de table
était ce rapport c'est vraiment de
pousser les choses donc on a besoin des
gens qui veulent pousser avec nous voilà
merci merci à tous les trois merci à
andré qui nous a déjà quitté en réaction
à québec
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté de
discuter aujourd'hui donc des suites du
rapport de l'amf ada et merci à vous
d'avoir été présent je vous rappelle que
nous serons encore une fois la la
semaine prochaine vendredi à 12h15 au
revoir